très vite et franklin ii ou s'il est
professeur à l'université de liège et
ans un ancien représentant spécial de la
belgique et ancien juge de la cour de
justice de l'union européenne
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france avant de parler de
la situation sanitaire en belgique
comprenez vous la colère des
professionnels du monde culturel
oui
elle est compréhensible parce que
[Musique]
communication
d'antan dans le gouvernement et
est pas vraiment une
on des arbitrages ont été faits contre
la culture a provoqué ans d'agitation
oui alors on l'a vu un cinéma un théâtre
et salles de concerts doivent fermer à
partir d'aujourd'hui pendant au moins
deux semaines alors que les restaurants
et les cafés peuvent ouvrir un jusqu'à
23 heures est ce qu'on peut parler d'une
différence de traitement
c'est certainement le reflet de la
valeur quasi constitutionnelle de la
bouffe en belgique c'est clair et les
gens du milieu culturel ne sont pas
contents du tout est ici et là vous
commencez à avoir de la désobéissance
dans l'application des règles alors
sanitairement il y dix ans comme icône
va être dominant d'ici quelques jours en
belgique mais en france également et
dans d'autres pays européens que pensez
vous justement de cette envie dire non
harmonie entre les pays de l'union
européenne et des pays européens plus
généralement
écouté c'est d'un côté il ya des aspects
sur lesquels il serait mieux d'avoir une
réaction collective plus forte notamment
sur la question des voyages des
déblocages aux frontières qui pose
beaucoup de gens beaucoup de problèmes
aux gens et aussi aux entreprises il
faut pas oublier qu'elles doivent
continuer à fonctionner dans le climat
difficile actuel maintenant en sens
inverse l'europe fait quand même
certaines choses en commun c'est
certainement vrai pour les vaccins nous
en aurions beaucoup moins si on ne les
avait pas
gérer collectivement et c'est valable
aussi pour les les traitements les
médicaments qui commencent à arriver et
aussi pour la redistribution d'argent
pour essayer de maintenir un
fonctionnement des budgets donc il ya
certains résultats mais ce n'est pas
optimal dirais-je justement on en est ou
au niveau de la vaccination en belgique
on sait que à partir point que depuis
lundi les autorités ont dit que cette
vaccination était ouverte pour les
enfants de 5 à 11 ans
exact a eu des résultats très en dents
de scie et la vaccination fait partie
des bons aspects ça continue maintenant
parce que elle a déjà un taux de 3e
vaccination ou bien de rva xi nation qui
est assez important mais malheureusement
au micro m'ont tellement vite que ça
crée quand même une peur au niveau des
hôpitaux notamment parce que le
personnel sanitaire est lui-même victime
de la pandémie et d'autre part il ya une
fatigue après presque deux ans alors on
sait qu'en france en sur la question de
la vaccination des enfants le
gouvernement a avancé en prudemment sur
la question un en belgique justement
cette vaccination des enfants comment
est elle perçue par les parents
elle est perçue de manière variée
évidemment les il ya des résistances et
les résistances s'exprime toujours de
manière plus intense je vous dirais que
ici aussi il ya des perceptions
contradictoires et mais il ya une partie
des parents dont la priorité est d'abord
d'assurer au maximum la continuité de
l'enseignement et il considère que dans
cette perspective il vaut mieux aller
vers la vaccination que vaut un risque
accru d'interruption à nouveau des cours
pour une période qu'on aperçoit mal
merci en tout cas vous franklin de
housses d'avoir été avec le d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur à l'université de
laives ancien représentant spécial de la
belgique et ancien juge à la cour de
justice de l'union européenne martial